hallo guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen bei ZDF heute live ich freue
mich sehr dass sie eingeschaltet habt um
hier wieder gemeinsam zu diskutieren ja
aber der Fußball-WM in Katar da ist
Deutschland ja ziemlich früh
rausgeflogen wer da aber ziemlich
unerwartet gerade richtig durchstartet
das sind die Marokkaner morgen spielen
die gegen Frankreich im WM Halbfinale
und sie sind damit auch das erste
arabische Land was quasi jemals bei
einer WM unter die letzten vier gekommen
ist dementsprechend groß ist da gerade
auch die Aufmerksamkeit und vor allem
der Jubel und Zuspruch aus wahnsinnig
vielen Ländern vielleicht habt ihr schon
Bilder von autokorses oder feiern den
Fans auf den Straßen gesehen welche
Bedeutung hat dieser marokkanische
Triumph für Menschen mit marokkanischen
Wurzeln in Deutschland aber auch
vielleicht im Rest der arabischen Welt
darüber wollen wir heute hier
diskutieren und zwar mit der deutschen
marokkanischen Journalistin sinab mit
unserer zdf-korrespondentin goliatai in
Doha und mit dem deutschen Mar
amerikanischen Comedian ab der Karim und
wir diskutieren natürlich auch mit euch
das heißt wenn ihr Fragen oder
Anmerkungen oder Kommentare für die drei
habt dann könnt ihr hier wie immer
mitdiskutieren schreibt uns gerne
einfach bei YouTube in den Chat oder per
Mail an ZDF heute - live at nee das war
falsch ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de ich bin gespannt auf
eure Kommentare jetzt sage ich aber
erstmal Hallo Abdel Karim schön dass du
bei uns bist hi
hallöchen ich grüße heißt
ich muss gerade lachen weil die Wand
sieht doch schon sehr einladend aus du
ich finde das sieht wunderbar aus wir
freuen uns sehr dass du bei uns bist
meine Frage an dich ganz persönlich was
bedeutet in dieser absolute Durchmarsch
der marokkanischen Mannschaft gerade für
dich ganz persönlich
für mich ganz persönlich also mein Leben
hat es nicht verändert so gesehen nicht
viel aber ich freue mich extremst weil
ich schon immer ein großer Fan dieser
marokkanischen Nationalmannschaft bin
und schon immer den Eindruck habe nicht
nur ich sondern viele andere machen
einer die verkaufen sich unter Wert und
da ist eigentlich viel mehr drin und
bisher war nicht viel dabei außer man
wurde gelobt für die schöne Spielweise
aber dann konnte man trotzdem die
Taschen packen wenn man sie überhaupt
ausgepackt hat beim Turnier letzte WM
zum Beispiel wurden wir durchgehend
gelohnt also die Mannschaft aber
trotzdem Schluss und jetzt sieht man
endlich mal dass sie auch kämpfen können
und auch mal weiterkommen und ganz neues
Gefühl das morgen ein Spiel ist und ein
einziges Spiel bei einer WM und Marokko
ist dabei so weit ist das Team schon
gekommen das ist doch grandios
du hast es gerade schon angesprochen was
bedeutet das denn für viele andere
vielleicht auch marokkanischstämmige
Menschen so in deinem Umfeld das jetzt
auf einmal ihrem Mannschaft quasi so
weit vorne ist was bedeutet das für eine
Community wie hier in Deutschland dies
vielleicht hier nicht immer einfach hat
ja die Probleme die man jetzt in
Deutschland haben sollte hier und da die
werden durch diesen durchmarschen
erwärmen zumindest bis zum Halbfinale
werden sich jetzt nicht ändern also
keine Wohnung bekommen hat vorher weil
er so aussieht will doch jetzt keine
Wohnung kriegen der kann ja nicht sagen
hör mal zu warum Halbfinale das wird
nicht viel helfen aber es ist trotzdem
eine geile Geschichte weil der hat sich
die letzten 30 40 Jahre sehr viel WM
Freude Vorbereitung angeschaut die nie
raus durfte und jetzt endlich darf doch
der Marokkaner seine Partner auspacken
und feiern aber ich glaube nicht dass
jetzt die ganzen
Alltagsprobleme die es gibt auf die Sie
vielleicht anspielen dass sie sich jetzt
groß ändern also das ist eine schöne
Anlass das ist Sport da freue ich mich
sehr und die Bilder zu sehen ist
grandios nicht nur die Marokkaner also
wirklich alle feiern mit großen Respekt
habe ich vor denen die nicht das Team
feiern weil da weiß man ganz genau die
Feiern heimlich weil diese Geschichte da
gibt es gar nicht mehr um Marokko die
muss man einfach feiern der absolute
anderthalb oder einer der absoluten
zuminde genau die Spieler nicht kennt
glaubt man es ist ein Underdog der dann
so eine Leistung zeigt das ist schon
sehr beeindruckend
ja du hast es gerade schon gesagt es
gibt auch Menschen die vielleicht gar
nicht Marokko jetzt als Team vorher so
gefeiert haben jetzt trotzdem mit feiern
was ist denn so dein Eindruck ist das
gerade auch wie so eine symbolhafte
Geschichte für die ganze arabische Welt
die da so ein Stück mehr zusammenrückt
oder würdest du sagen das geht nicht so
weit
auch schon die Bilder sind ja eindeutig
es ist aber nicht nur so dass die
arabische Welt feiert was auch immer
alles unter der arabischen Welt so
gepackt wird sondern es feiern wirklich
alle also ich habe mir auf Youtube ganz
viele Videos angesehen das sind noch
Italiener die sagen hey viel Spaß Grüße
aus Italien aus Österreich ganz Afrika
der Kontinent feiern sogar noch viel
mehr weil seit Ewigkeiten hört man das
endlich mal Zeit für afrikanischen
erfolgreich
und weil die Spieler sind da Afrika hat
immer wieder grandiose Spieler aber
irgendwie hat es nie gereicht um so weit
zu kommen und das ist natürlich tolle
Geschichte aber man sieht wirklich ich
freue mich besonders über die Folge der
Algeria weil politisch hier und da gibt
es zwischen Marokko und Algerien und
Algerien einfach
Unklarheiten aktuell und da freue ich
mich sehr dass die Bevölkerung aber
zeigt dass man sich als ein Bruder von
sich meinetwegen
hast oder nicht ich finde es toll das
freut mich da am meisten aber ich freue
mich über jeden der sich mit freut
über diese Geschichte
und man sieht eindeutig dass in der WM
in Katar ist es definitiv so dass es den
Turnier sehr gut getan hat das ein Land
aus dem magretten Marokko so weit
gekommen ist vor allem mit den mit den
Fans also Argentino Marokko ohne die
beiden Fangruppen wäre die WM auf jeden
Fall ein bisschen langweiliger
du hast gerade schon vom WM-Titel
gesprochen bis dahin sind ja noch quasi
zwei große Herausforderungen lass uns
mal auf das Spiel morgen gucken das hat
ja noch mal eine ganz besondere
Bedeutung da heißt es dann Marokko gegen
Frankreich und was diese Partie so
besonders macht das hat sich eine ahren
für uns angeguckt
Jubel auf den Champs Elysee französische
und marokkanische Fans am Wochenende
feierten sie noch gemeinsam den Einzug
ins Halbfinale ihrer Mannschaften die
nun gegeneinander antreten werden manch
einer spricht von einem Bruder Duell so
spielen in mbappé Frankreich Stürmer und
Hakimi Marokkos Verteidiger zusammen bei
PSG sind befreundet und nicht nur die
beiden verbindet vielen
Dank besonders es Leben enorm viele
Marokkaner in Frankreich das wird eine
Riesenparty und dann haben wir Spieler
ja auch schon einiges zusammen erlebt
rögie Marokko so wie viele seiner
Spieler sind in Frankreich geboren
unterdessen Protektorat Marokko
beißen sich die Atlas Löwen durch was
sie vom Favoriten trennt ihr Marktwert
deutlich unter Frankreich und auch die
Anzahl antiteln doch in der Gunst der
Fans liegen sie beide gleich auf es lebe
marokko ist Liebe Frankreich möge der
beste gewinnen
Außenseiter gegen Titelverteidiger es
wird ein Abend voller Emotionen
[Applaus]
genau wir haben es gerade gehört marokko
hat zu Frankreich vielleicht noch mal
andere Beziehung als jetzt Marokko zu
Deutschland marokko ist nämlich
ehemaliges französisches Protektorat was
glaubst du wie würdest du das
Einschätzen ist das jetzt für ein
marokkanische Person die in Frankreich
lebt hat das noch mal eine andere
Bedeutung mit dieser Beziehung die die
beiden Länder haben
bin ich mir ganz sicher dass Marokko
eine Kolonie früher war dann merkt man
doch am ein oder anderen Kommentator im
deutschen Fernsehen das Thema
organischen Namen Französisch
ausgesprochen werden da wird man auf
was ich aber gar nicht schlimm finde
lustig dass man denkt man muss die Namen
Französisch aussprechen aber ich weiß
selber wie es mir ging also ich gehört
habe wenn die Gruppe E Deutschlands
einigermaßen läuft spielt Deutschland
gegen Marokko und das wäre für mich auf
jeden Fall ein sehr besonderes Spiel als
fußballverrückter Fußballfeld und das
ist definitiv jetzt Derby Frankreich
Marokko also nicht nur der Trainer ist
überhaupt geworden sondern aufrufen und
scheiß die beiden auf jeden Fall ich
glaube so viele Frankreich geborene
Spieler sind im Kader gar nicht Moment
und das ist für die eine riesen riesen
Nummer also das ist definitiv ein riesen
Erlebnis und für die Marokko lebenden
Marokko Franzosen ist es auf jeden Fall
der absolute also das Spiel ist ein
Derby muss man einfach so sagen
und ich hoffe es wird ein schönes Spiel
mit schönen Szenen nachgespielt die
Spieler kennen sich ja eh alle aus
verschiedenen Turnieren und spielen und
dass die dann hoffentlich auf dem Platz
ein Zeichen setzen und das das nicht
ausartet
ja und jetzt interessiert mich zum
Schluss natürlich noch mal was dein Tipp
fürs Spiel morgen ist was glaubst du wie
das ausgeht
marokko hat ja schon quasi gewonnen aber
der Trainer hat es geschafft dass die
wirklich daran glauben dass es sehr weit
gehen kann deswegen hoffe ich ganz stark
auf ein zwei eins aber wenn es ein Team
gibt dass diese grandiose Abwehr marokko
ist irgendwie stören kann dann
Frankreich mit diesem grandiosen einzeln
können dem wähle und mbappé und
Grießmann vor allem der mich selber
überrascht weil da dachten alle viele
schon fertig mit Fußball 2:1 für
Frankreich und ich weiß dass das sehr
unrealistisch ist aber da waren ja
einige Spiele schon realistisch
wir sind auf jeden Fall gespannt wie das
morgen ausgeht danke ab der Karin dass
du bei uns warst schönen Abend noch wir
reiten den Ciao wir warten den Blick
jetzt mal von einer Deutsch
marokkanischen Perspektive so ein
bisschen auf das Geschehen aus und
schalten zum Ort des Geschehens über
dass wir die ganze Zeit sprechen nämlich
zur WM in Katar und zu meiner Kollegin
golini hallo
hallo
erzähl uns mal wo stehst du da gerade
ich stehe in einem Einkaufszentrum wo
gleich ein Public Viewing stattfindet
Spiel Argentinien Kroatien
ja das ist natürlich das andere Spiel
auf dem gerade ganz viel Aufmerksamkeit
liegt wenn ihr Fragen an Golly näh habt
dann schickt sie gerne hier bei YouTube
in den Chat oder schreibt uns eine Mail
an ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de
aus deiner Erfahrung der letzten Tage
und Wochen du bist halt schon eine Zeit
da wer jubelt denn in Katha für Marokko
sehr sehr viele zuvor dass die
katharerinnen und Katara selber auch die
Familie des Emirs jubelt für Marokko
halt demonstrativ immer die Marokko
Flagge hoch aber auch ganz ganz viele
arabische experts hier haben wir sehr
viele Jordania Palästinenser Libanesen
Sudanesen ja eine Art zweite Heimat
gefunden und dementsprechend gut besucht
sind die Fans Zonen wenn das Marokko
Team spielt
ja du sprichst gerade an es gibt eine
große Begeisterung in der arabischen
Welt für dieses Team und du hast doch
angesprochen dass man ab und zu mal die
Palästinenser Flagge sieht wenn Marokko
gewinnt wie müssen wir das verstehen was
bedeutet die
ja die marokkanische Nation Nationalelf
hat ja im Stadion auf dem Rasen die
Palästina Flagge gezeigt und sich auch
mit ihr fotografieren lassen es gibt
sehr viele arabische expert hier die die
palästinensische Flagge neben der
marokkanischen aus schwingen ganz
bewusst es gibt viele Palästinenser hier
die mit der Flagge zu sehen sind und man
scherzt dir das Palästina ja so so etwas
wie die 33 Nation ist die hier an der WM
quasi mitmacht
man muss sich das vor diesem Hintergrund
vor Augen halten als dass viele
arabische Regierungen ja mittlerweile
mit Israel gute diplomatische
Beziehungen gute wirtschaftliche
Beziehungen haben zum Beispiel die
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate Marokko
selbst aber auch der Sudan das aber die
Herzen der Bevölkerung der Herzen der
Araberinnen und Araber oft anders
schlagen und die Sympathien oft woanders
liegen natürlich kann man jetzt eine
Diskussion führen und die
palästinensische die Flagge im Stadion
auf dem Rasen als politisches Symbol und
dann kann sich natürlich als Fan Fragen
moment mal wieso ist die Flagge
eigentlich erlaubt von der FIFA und
andere Insignien sind nicht erlaubt aber
bislang hat die FIFA solche
Medienanfragen unbeantwortet gelassen
dazu
du hast es gerade schon so ein bisschen
angesprochen marokko hat ja als
innerhalb der arabischen Welt oft gar
nicht so einen einfachen stand weil es
auch sehr offene diplomatische Beziehung
zu Israel
führt welche Bedeutung hat denn jetzt
quasi politisch diese WM vielleicht für
Marokko so im Konstrukte arabischen Welt
also insgesamt geht es bei dieser
arabischen gemeinsamen Erfahrung so ein
bisschen auch um die Aufwertung der
eigenen Identität das geht um die
emotionale Aufarbeitung von
Diskriminierungserfahrungen das höre ich
zumindest in den Interviews ja oft
heraus viele Katara sagen mir
wir in der islamischen Welt in der
arabischen Welt wir können nicht nur WM
wir können nicht nur eine WM ausrichten
wir haben auch eine arabische Mannschaft
die sogar das Halbfinale erreichen kann
und dementsprechend stolz dass man dann
darauf zu sehen dass diese marokkanische
Mannschaft zum Beispiel eine enge
Familienverbundenheit zeigt zum Beispiel
dass die dass die Spieler das einige
Spieler sich demonstrativ mit ihren
Müttern zum Beispiel zeigen auf dem
Rasen das gilt als ein besonderes Symbol
auch in der arabische in der islamischen
Welt in der arabischen Welt man ist
besonders stolz darauf dass sie zum
Beispiel islamische Gesten auf dem Rasen
zeigen ähnlich wie sich andere Spieler
bekreuzigen würden und
dass wir jetzt ein bisschen als eine
gemeinsame Erfahrung hier aufgefasst und
man fühlt sich aneinander verbunden
ja also quasi eine Aufwertung eine Image
Aufwertung vielleicht auch genau für
diese islamische Welt die wieder gerade
bei dieser WM erleben du hast es schon
angesprochen es werden zum Teil
Insignien gezeigt oder Flaggen gezeigt
andere werden von der FIFA ja nicht
geduldet wie blickt man denn so in der
arabischen Community dort vor Ort auf
diese Diskurse dieses Jahr in Europa und
in Deutschland vor allem auch gab vor
den Beginn dieser WM wie guckt man auf
diese moralischen Diskurse und Debatten
die es gab Thema Menschenrechte Thema
Diversity in Katar
also auch wenn viele Araberinnen und
Araber in Ländern leben in denen es um
die Menschenrechte nicht wirklich gut
bestellt ist
ist unsere Diskussion über
Menschenrechte über Minderheitenrechte
nicht wirklich spiegelbildlich auf den
arabischen Raum zu übertragen und das
sieht man ganz besonders an den
Diskussionen die hier geführt worden
sind was die regenbogen-armbänder angeht
habe ich oft gehört ihr wollt uns eure
Werte aufzwingen überstülpen sozusagen
auf diktieren auch was zum Beispiel die
Geste der deutschen Nationalelf angeht
sich die Hand vor den Mund zu halten das
ist ja extrem negativ aufgepasst worden
als ein Indiz für deutsche Doppelmoral
oft ist mir hier die Frage entgegen
gekommen wieso hat die deutsche national
erst 2018 in Russland keine Geste des
Protestes gezeigt als Wladimir Putin ja
viele Bombenangriffe gegen Syrien
gefahren hat ich glaube so ein bisschen
auch als Antwort darauf wird hier das
eine sehr betont zum Beispiel
dass man eben stolz darauf ist dass es
die erste arabische Nation die erste
islamische Nation ist die diese WM
ausrichtet zum Beispiel auch der Stolz
auf Katha dass es sich gegen den Druck
aus dem Westen durchgesetzt habe was die
regenbogenarbenbinder angeht oder das
Alkoholverbot an den Stadien und Kata
nutzt ja die Plattform dieser
Weltmeisterschaft auch dafür für den
Islam Werbung zu machen gegen Vorurteile
gegenüber Muslimen auch aufmerksam zu
machen und ja für seine Version des
Islam auch zu werden
ja ist auf jeden Fall eine super
spannende Entwicklung die du da gerade
beschreibst danke dass du bei uns warst
wir sind gespannt was uns dann im
Nachgang von morgen erzählen wirst danke
schön
wir sprechen jetzt hier gerade viel über
den sportlichen Erfolg Marokkos wir
wollen aber noch mal so ein bisschen
politisch und vor allem historisch auf
das Land gucken und das hat Christian
Volk für uns gemacht
über die Jahrhunderte haben sich in
Marokko zahlreiche Kulturen vermischt
die ursprüngliche Bevölkerung Berber
traditionell leben sie damals als
sesshafte Bauern oder Nomaden im achten
Jahrhundert erobern arabische Truppen
die Region sie bringen den Islam ins
Land sind wichtig für die weitere
kulturelle Entwicklung der Region im 18
und 19 Jahrhundert Gerät Marokko immer
mehr in den Blick der europäischen
Großmächte Großbritannien das Deutsche
Reich vor allem aber Frankreich und
Spanien wollen ihre Interessen in
Nordafrika sichern nach mehreren Kriegen
bringen die Spanier die marokkanische
Mittelmeerküste unter ihre Herrschaft
die Franzosen den restlichen Teil des
landeszentral Marokko Berber und Araber
kämpfen gegen die Besatzer Aufstände
werden blutig niedergeschlagen erst 1956
bekommt Marokko seine Unabhängigkeit
zurück wird zur Monarchie trotz
Verfassung und Reformen ist bis heute
der König der starkem Mann im Staat
unter dem amtierenden Monarchen Moor mit
dem sechsten kämpft das Land seit Jahren
mit Armut und hoher
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit
ja wir sehen Marokko ein Land mit
bewegter Geschichte vor allem mit einer
sich ständig wechselnden Beziehung zu
Europa und jetzt begrüße ich bei mir die
deutsche marokkanische Journalistin und
Autorin sinab schön dass Sie da sind
guten Abend hallo
Entschuldigung welche Bedeutung hat
dieser sportliche Erfolg Marokkos für
Sie ganz persönlich und Sie haben ja
auch ein Bezug zu Marokko was ist
vielleicht auch so die Wirkung in
Marokko also erstmal ist Marokko ein
fußballbegeisterter Staat die marokko
ist seit 1960 Mitglied der FIFA also da
sieht man schon die lange Tradition
innerhalb dieses Sport Konstrukt und
1970 hat es zum ersten Mal aneinander WM
war teilgenommen also ja das
afrikanische Herz im Fußball schlägt
lange marokkanisch und ähm was welche
Bedeutung das für mich hat ist es Teil
meiner Identität und ich freue mich
natürlich dass ein Teil meiner ident
nämlich den marokkanische jetzt auch in
Deutschland in Europa in der Welt auch
sichtbar gemacht wird wenn wir uns
Deutschland anschauen gibt es rund
85.000 marokkanisch stämmige Menschen
hier zu Lande also weniger als
beispielsweise Syrer oder die Türkei
stämmige Community und das bringt
natürlich einfach auch noch mal
Spotlight auf eine Gemeinschaft die eben
hier seit sehr vielen Jahren oder
Jahrzehnten eigentlich genau genommen in
Deutschland lebt
ja sie sprechen es gerade schon an wie
viele Marokkaner Marokkanerinnen aktuell
in Deutschland leben lassen Sie uns an
dieser Stelle mal darauf gucken wo die
marokkanische Diaspora überall lebt
genau also das spannend aktuell leben
rund 5 Millionen Menschen marokkanischer
Herkunft außerhalb Marokkos die meisten
davon in Europa der größte Teil in
Frankreich dort sind es rund 1,6
Millionen Menschen in Spanien 1,3
Millionen in Israel machen rund 900.000
Menschen aus Marokko bzw mit
marokkanischen Vorfahren ca 10% der
Bevölkerung aus in Italien gibt es rund
800.000 weit abgeschlagen dagegen
Deutschland hier leben nur rund 86.000
Menschen marokkanischer Herkunft
ja da bin ich ihnen quasi mit meiner
Grafik gerade ins Wort gefallen
aufgezeigt worden genau warum sitzt
einfach noch mal ein bisschen bildlich
untermalt da sieht man vielleicht noch
mal ganz gut dass das vielleicht morgen
auch noch mal ein besonderes Matches
zwischen Frankreich und Marokko in
Deutschland gibt es deutlich weniger
Marokkaner Marokkanerin wir haben jetzt
ja in den Bildern der letzten Wochen
nach Siegen marokko ist auch immer
wieder gesehen dass sich in all die
Freude von Menschen mit marokkanischen
Wurzeln eben auch gerade in Paris und
Brüssel so eine Art Aufstand gemischt
hat da wurden Dinge beschädigt wie
müssen wir uns das denn erklären also
zunächst einmal bereitet Fußball vielen
Menschen weltweit eben auch in Europa
Freude es gibt anders zu feiern und
Ausgelassenheit zum Tanzen sich in den
Arm nehmen kennt man ja von vielen
Fußball spielen leider Gottes gibt es
natürlich bei Fuß Fußball spielen
natürlich auch immer Randalierer also
das muss man gar nicht so weit in die
Ferne schauen jedes länderspiel
birgt immer viele Randalierer die sich
ja in Stadien aber eben auch auf der
Straße in der Bahn sehr stark daneben
benehmen und das haben wir natürlich
jetzt leider eben auch vor einiger Zeit
in Belgien gesehen in Holland bei dem
Spiel Marokko gegen Belgien und jetzt
vor kurzem in Paris also das ist etwas
womit wir natürlich weiterhin rechnen
müssen aber ganz wichtig die Mehrheit
freut sich die Mehrheit feiert und eine
kleine Minderheit ja hat tatsächlich
kein Respekt vor dem Eigentum anderer
und
gefährdet tatsächlich vor allem ja das
Leben und die die Gesundheit von
Menschen die einfach nur ausgelassen
miteinander diesen besonderen Zeit
erleben möchten
ja lassen Sie uns mal so ein bisschen
auf die Bilder schauen nachdem Marokko
die Spiele gewonnen hat da haben wir wir
haben es gerade schon kurz angesprochen
auch immer wieder muslimische Gesten
gesehen beispielsweise beten nach dem
Spiel oder diesen erhobenen Zeigefinger
was glauben Sie denn wie viel dieser
aktuellen arabischen Freude oder
Euphorie ist vielleicht auch eine
muslimische Freude also das ist spannend
ist und das war ja so schön dass sie das
noch mal in der Grafik gezeigt haben die
dritte größte die drittgrößte
marokkanische stämmige Diaspora lebt in
Israel das heißt die marokkanische
Identität ist sowohl muslimisch als auch
jüdisch und wenn wir sozusagen die die
Euphorie der rund um die Marokkaner
Beleuchtung zeigen wir vor allem weil
die sehr stark arabisch muslimische
Seite der
Nationaltrainer betont ja tatsächlich
noch mal das die marokkanische
Nationalmannschaft vor allem eine
afrikanische ist also das
Selbstverständnis
zu sein und vor allem eine afrikanischer
Staat der vor einem arabische ist also
marokko ist sehr vielschichtig auch die
Einflüsse Europas spielen natürlich da
auch noch mal eine Rolle zeigen
natürlich dass der die Fokussierung auf
das muslimische in dem Fall jetzt auch
von der Mannschaft selbst ausgeht indem
Sie beispielsweise den erhobenen Finger
zeigen den man gerne mal als is-finger
bezeichnet jetzt ist es so dass
sozusagen das Glaubensbekenntnis und
viele in Siegen lernen aber auch ähm ja
Riten die man aus dem Islam kennt die
eigentlich überhaupt nicht bedrohlich
sind die auch nicht bedeuten dass man
andere Menschen davon oder damit wir
verjagen oder bekämpfen möchte dass das
natürlich islamistische Gruppierungen
gerne für sie für ihre Propaganda und
für ihre Allmacht Fantasien missbrauchen
und das haben wir in dem Fall des is
auch welche Intention jetzt die
einzelnen Spieler mit diesen Symbolen
bezweckt haben das kann ich jetzt gar
nicht bewerten dafür müsste man mit den
selber sprechen ich könnte mir jetzt
durchaus vorstellen dass vielleicht das
National Team jetzt vielleicht auch
nicht unbedingt die muslimische oder die
die marokkanische Geschichte und die
teilt ob es dann auch immer angebracht
ist ja das kann man dann irgendwie auf
einer anderen Ebene noch mal diskutieren
aber ich denke was eindeutig was man
eindeutig sagen kann dass es sich jetzt
hier nicht um Menschen handelt die vor
allem irgendwie in irgendeiner Form den
islamischen Staat sich jetzt
zurückwünschen
das haben wir eben schon mit goldene so
ein bisschen angerissen dass es hier
gerade auch darum geht dass der Islam
vielleicht in der Welt Aufmerksamkeit
noch mal ein ganz neues Image bekommt
was würden Sie sagen was sind da so die
Unterschiede oder was was verändert sich
da gerade
also momentan gibt es glaube ich einfach
eine enorme Sehnsucht sich zu freuen und
dadurch dass es sich hier bei Marokko
und um ein Land handelt was mehrheitlich
muslimisch ist was vor allem die
arabische Sprache nutzt
gibt es natürlich dieses
Selbstverständnis jetzt sind wir Muslime
auch mal erfolgreich der National
Trainer er hat ja dieses Bild von Rocky
Balboa so einem Underdog auch noch mal
Gezeichnet mit Marokko hat kaum jemand
gerechnet und plötzlich ja kommt ein
Land immer mehr in den Fokus der Welt
Öffentlichkeit ähm das vor allem
muslimisch und vor allem auf dem
afrikanischen Kontinent ist und was
jetzt ganz viele
arabischstämmige Menschen vereint also
ich weiß noch als Marokko gegen Spanien
gewonnen hat hatte ich ganz viele
Nachrichten von Bekannten die die selbst
lieber diese Stämme mich hat es denen
sie ständig da gibt es ständig sind die
mir dann gesagt haben hey ihr seid
gerade richtig groß
Tom und alle feiern euch und das hat
sicherlich auch ein bisschen mit der
Symbolik mit der palästinensischen
Flagge zu tun aber eben auch der
Tatsache dass es sich hierbei um Muslime
handelt und es gibt so einen leichten
Minderwertigkeitskomplex innerhalb des
Westens aber auch in der Welt das alles
was mit Muslimen zu tun hat meistens mit
Terrorismus und ja nicht so besonders
schön Schlagzeilen zu tun hat wenn wir
uns Deutschland anschauen wir denken an
die silvestern nach aber eben auch die
Terroranschläge und der Islamismus ist
natürlich ein großes Problem und ähm
hier müsste man aber auch noch mal sagen
dass der Islamismus sowohl in der
muslimischen Welt als auch im Westen ein
großes Problem darstellt und eigentlich
beide Seiten da die gleichen Kämpfe
auszutragen haben jetzt haben wir mit
Katana natürlich einem Land was
natürlich den den Islamismus leider
leider maßgeblich auch unterstützt
ja auf jeden Fall spannende insights und
Fragen man ich habe es eben schon mal
goldene angesprochen wenn man jetzt noch
mal so ein bisschen darauf guckt wer
guckt da gerade in Katha zu wer jubelt
da sieht man ja auf einmal
Staatsoberhäupter arabische
Staatsoberhäupter nebeneinander jubeln
beispielsweise den Emir von Katha und
den Kronprinz aus Saudi Arabien das sind
Bilder die hat man jetzt vor ein paar
Jahren so noch nicht erwartet ich frage
mich jetzt gibt's da wirklich ein
Potenzial dass diese WM vielleicht auch
so ein bisschen politisch nachwirkt im
arabischen Raum oder ist das dann
wirklich nur quasi die Freude des Sports
also ich denke vor allem ist es ist
jetzt jeder im Rausch alle freuen sich
alle wollen feiern und sie haben jetzt
einen Grund zu feiern man feiert sich
selbst um ähm um eine gute Freundin zu
zitieren selbst palästinente stelle mich
Hauptsache stolz sein das ist jetzt die
Stunde dafür am Ende des Tages werden
die Staaten vor allem ihre eigene
nationalen und wirtschaftlichen
Interessen durchsetzen Marokko fliegt zu
vielen vielen Staaten des Westens aber
auch das Nahen Osten sehr gute
Beziehungen
dementsprechend wird man sich da schon
in irgendeiner Form einigen aber es gibt
eine Redewendung die Araber haben sich
darauf geeinigt sich nicht zu einigen
und ich glaube die werden sich
wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen treu
bleiben
ja wenn wir uns noch mal den Blick so
von quasi die arabischen Kosmos ein
bisschen rauszoomen dann gibt es ja
gerade auch oft diese Erzählungen dieses
narrativ das was wir da gerade sehen das
ist quasi auch so ein bisschen wie so
ein Fight globale südkugel gegen alte
Kolonialmächte die jetzt so ein bisschen
aufholen finden Sie denn dieses narrativ
passt gut jetzt auf den Erfolg Marokkos
ich glaube die Frage ist wem geben wir
Raum die eigenen narrative auch in die
Öffentlichkeit zu tragen es gibt auf
jeden Fall dieses narrativ das hat
natürlich was mit der jeweiligen
Geschichte des jeweiligen Landes zu tun
marokko ist ja nicht erst seit der
Unabhängigkeit 1956 einen Monarchie also
Marokko war beispielsweise ein Land was
selbst überhaupt nicht unter der Osman
unter dem Osmanischen Reich ähm
eingegliedert was war eine sehr alte
Monarchie im Grunde genommen ist die
sogar älter also fast so alt wie die
britische und dementsprechend haben sie
da noch mal eine andere Position
innerhalb in dieses dieses Gefüge ist
aber da gibt es natürlich viele
Kränkungen und viele auch negative
Erfahrungen innerhalb der
Kolonialgeschichte die sicherlich dieses
Gefühl auch noch mal verstärkt aber was
wir nicht außer Acht lassen dürfen und
das wird halt noch mal bei dieser bei
diesem bei diesem bei diesem Thema auch
noch mal deutlich es sind Menschen
die das Spielen die vor allem in Europa
sozialisiert sind also ihre Erfolge
haben sie zum Teil eben auch super zu
verdanken und gleichzeitig sind sie ihm
verwurzelt mit dem nordafrikanischen
Land Marokko und so geht es vielen
vielen anderen Menschen aus ehemaligen
Kolonien am Ende auch die Vermischung
und die Verwurzelung ist viel viel
größer als eben in diesem ich und wir
und ihr zu denken und ich hoffe dass
natürlich dieser Spirit der Freude sich
vielleicht auch auf diese Debatten
überträgt und man wirklich mehr die
Gemeinsamkeiten anerkennt und der
Streben auch noch Freiheit nach selbst
Entfaltung und eben auch Emanzipation
also wenn wir ganz kurz noch den
Schwenker zum Thema one der one
love-binde und überhaupt Freiheitsrechte
lgbtq-rechte werden auch in vielen
arabischen muslimischen Ländern
eingefordert auch dort gibt es
Bewegungen also es ist nichts was
sozusagen nur im Westen existiert der
Westen hat Gott sei Dank sich diese
Rechte erkennt und den vielen vielen
muslimischen Ländern ist das eben noch
ein harter Alter und in dem Moment hätte
man vielleicht eben sich auch für all
die Menschen stark gemacht die Ländern
leben aktuell sehen wir gerade die
Situation im Iran wo Menschen wirklich
für Freiheit und selbst und Entfaltung
auch kämpfen das ist eben ja ein
tatsächlich globales Thema
ja auf jeden Fall super spannend was
diese Weltmeisterschaft alles für
politische Debatten aufwirft und anstößt
und weiterführt vielen Dank Frau masara
dass sie bei uns waren vielen vielen
Dank
ja ich habe hier von euch noch mal so
ein paar Spieltipps wie es morgen
ausgehen könnte YouTube User City Jack
City Jack sag Marokko wird gewinnen 2:0
ähm und auch
nur auf youtube ist sich sicher dass
Marokko gewinnt Marokko 3 Frankreich 1
und dann haben wir noch einen
Erklärungsansatz für den großen Erfolg
der marokkanischen Mannschaft von äh
music Freak auf Youtube er sagt bei der
marokkanischen Mannschaft dreht sich
nicht um die Binde und um moralisches
deshalb können die frei ausspielen
wahrscheinlich auch in Bezug auf die
moralische Debatte die wir in
Deutschland vor der WM geführt haben ich
tippe jetzt mal gar nichts ich gucke mir
das aber morgen mal an und guck wie es
da um eure Tipps besteht wir sind
gespannt wie es morgen ausgeht ich freue
mich wenn ihr wieder einschaltet bei ZDF
heute live